okay what up guys welcome to morning
coffee thoughts
it's your host Pearl today I'm
I am so sore like I'm so freaking sore
you don't even understand my trainer
killed me one day
um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification by the way you're going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in also sign up for my
memberships
um
if you want to see like behind the
scenes Vlogs um that's at the second
tier and I have a Discord now so that's
exciting
um
anyways
so today I'm talking about common
attacks
that people use against me and a lot of
times people in these videos will say
well if you don't care
why do you why do you talk about it or
like you're giving oxygen to it and I'm
like maybe I am
but I just think these videos are
entertaining
and I think they're more entertaining
when I talk about these things so
I want to go through the attacks that
people that disagree with me start with
so they'll first start
with something about my looks so it'll
be like either my face or my body or
like
something about something looks wise
that's always first and you're like okay
and then second is
they'll say well you're in the
manosphere and like the men in the
minosphere wouldn't rate you highly
either and like you wouldn't be like
valuable to a high value man and I'm
like okay yeah
I'd agree probably not
and
then they would be like well now you
have low self-esteem and that's why you
do it and I'm just like
if I say
high value man is like 10 of the
population maybe even smaller probably
even probably five percent
do I think I'm in the top five percent
of women
no that's delusional
and I don't think it's low self-esteem
to say you know what yeah
I may not yeah I may not qualify for
that you know just you know
but you know that's that's just me
that's just me so
that then that then this gives them like
ammo
to psychoanalyze me because they'll be
like okay
she's insecure and then they'll just go
off about me being insecure
and I'm like yeah I'm insecure about
some things but
I wouldn't say that's the root of my
opinions you know I would say it's more
based on like the things I think you
know but you know call me call me
old-fashioned I don't know
am I
and my line of work we think that women
can have an opinion
if you know but you can call me crazy
then then step three so after they say
you're insecure psychoanalyze me that
way they're like
you just want attention from Men
and you're just saying this first
because men will like you and and you
get no attention from Men I'm like okay
calm down
calm down let's not
I keep the dating part of my life online
that is a lesson I learned
I don't
I
I've learned that ruins relationships
and I don't need y'all to know what's
going on
in that area of my life but I
yeah they need to they need to calm down
it's just like I'm like I promise you an
average girl can get attention from that
it's not it's not and then they'll be
like oh well now you're hanging around
the guys and like it's so weird like
it's just this weird phenomenon it's
like instead of attacking the argument
they go personal
now you could argue could argue
that it's because I say things like
whales
and you could argue that I'm a bit rude
I could see that but here's the thing
I've only personally called someone a
whale once if you feel like the shoe
fits that's not my fault
that is not my fault
um I have only and the only reason I
personally called this woman a whale
was because she attacked me okay a lot
of people don't even know that's where
I'm pretty sure that's where it started
I don't want to say that's where it
started because sometimes I say things
and then the comments section will give
me receipts and I'm like oh [ __ ] okay
but I'm like pretty sure that's where it
started because basically this woman
okay
I'll reenact it I was doing Street
interviews so I was like
interview interview and I'm this woman
basically is calling me a slag and my
friend had to hold her back so she
wouldn't like hit me and she knocks the
mic out of my hand and she's like you're
effing slag you're an inside and I did
not know what a slag meant but I knew I
was being insulted I knew I was being
insulted so I said and you what and
you're a whale and you're a whale
yeah that's where it started if anyone
was wondering
um
yeah that's been wearing coffee pot
s or topics it's weird it's like it's
it's Circle it's like it starts because
I kind of cycle psychoanalyze the the
people commenting because there's just
so many like
how do you put it common things where
it's like all these people are going
through the same Loop like first it's
like well your looks aren't that good
anyway and then the next thing is well
you're single anyway and then which
chill out and and then the next thing is
like
um
what's after looks single then well
you're just insecure and then you're
like okay well maybe about some things
but I wouldn't say that's the root of my
opinion and then they go into well you
um
what was next you're just insecure
you're just
oh you just want attention from men and
these men don't want you and you get no
attention
okay yeah you're right no no attention
here
[Music]
um
yeah and it's like a circle and they
never really I've had like one reaction
video that I saw really attack the
argument but most of them are just going
after my looks
my dating life or
psychoanalyzing me that's like a weird
thing that women mostly do I've seen a
couple men do it but it's like why are
you psychoanalyzing me
I actually hate it when women
psychoanalyze I I have a friend that
does this and it irritates the living F
out of me you're not a psychologist
um one and two
you don't know and then three like what
does it matter like let's say you
psychoanalyze that person and they're
they're uh
or whatever like gonna call them
insecure narcissist whatever it doesn't
change the fact anyways I I just hate it
that's like a pet peeve of mine I hate
hate it
when my friends like psychoanalyze
people it just annoys me anyways
um but let me know in the comments what
you guys think
um
let me know I tried chai tea with just
water today and it's actually decent
I was not expecting I'm on a tea Journey
I'm on a tea Journey because I'm I'm
trying to quit drinking coffee and
eating coffee out and just only doing it
in my apartment
um I will say that I've been doing this
for months and you can find months of me
talking about how I'm gonna quit coffee
in different ways and I usually don't
but you know
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell and I will talk to you next time